Woah!
Oh... oh wow
Oh wow, so bootyful (god, pewds)
Oh!
That's more like it
*lols*
Woah-- What the hell, omg, you're so kyooooot
Cyka Blyat
Eya Cyka
Whoah
Oh no
How do I change?
How do I get out of this outfit?
Hey can I pet you?
....
Excuse me kitty, hey kitty
Kitty! Kitty! Kitty! Kitty! Kitty!
Kitty lemme touch you
Oh... do you like that kitty?
Hey, son, don't change, can I look at your butt?
Please, stay there
Lemme look at you, I just wanna look at you
Alright, now stay there...
Turn around
Come on, that's right, let me loo-
Shake that ass for me
Oh hell yea
Dauren you wanna be my boyfriend?
What are you gay or something? Come on
[Dauren] You'll find someone sometime
Thank you may be one day
[Dauren] Hopefully
Hey, anyone of you, you wanna join me?
[Dauren] Oh hell yea
You wanna join me?
That's what I'm talking about
Hey it's Maaaarkiplier, everybody
[dude] Hey, Markiplier
I'm the real Maaaaaaarkiplier
Does anyone wanna touch me?
[dude] No.
Fine. You know what, that's fair
[dude] Can ioo du lis?
Hehehehe
No I can't cause I'm Maaaaarkiplier (laughing)
Make sure to subscribe to keemstar
But can you...?
Aw, Shit, can you do this? *explosion*
(freaks out cuz of low pitch noise)
JESUS CHRIST
[human] You are the worst human
Don't listen to him. You are the worst human
[human] I'm like, a generic white guy
Of course, I'm the worst human.
That's True that's probably true.
(Pewds aren't you white though?)
Alright now apologize to Shawn
Sorry Shawn
[human] Sorry Shawn
Yeah that's right. Now kiss him
Go ahead and kiss.
Kiss and make up
Cmon, Shawn, don't be shy.
[human] He's too short
It's fine just bend over ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Shawn you gotta jump
You've got to jump for this to happen, Shawn.
*sexy music starts*
Yes! Yes! Come on
Kiss, kiss
KISS
*human talking creep shit*
[human] Get your ass over here boi
Come on Shawn
Don't be shy
Woah look at those moves
Come on Shawn
Come on jump, you just gotta jump like this.
Hah
Come on, alright, how about this, I kiss you instead hah. :* :*
How about that, come on, I'll kiss you for Shawn
[human] Uhrgh yes, yes
[human] Thank you
I'm still too short
[human] Uuh... soo gud
[human] It's so good
Wait-wa-wa-wa-wait
If I stand up here and I go this way
And then you can kiss my ass, how about that. Hah.
If you make fun of Shawn.
You played the consequences
What happened?
Think I lost connection. (You didn't paid)
Great
Come on! hahaha
What is happening
(Technical difficulties)
Oh my God, I'm in Harry Potter land!
[HP] Oh yeah
Oh my God, it's harry potter!
[HP] Yeah, that's me oooo
Fabulous *thank you*
*high five* He he
Give me. Give me some.
Keep doing what you doing Harry
*Okay i'm gonna do something dude*
*Hey dude, listen up, listen up* Oh not to close.
*You know when* No you listen up *Shut the fuck up* (dude got no chill)
*yeah, when you have a VR*
*When you have a VR*
*We can grab a sword*
*A gun* Right.
A gun, Oh my God, what are you wearing.
*Look this is the most f*kin worthless scheme ever*
*It's a Harry Potter without a magic wand* (No shit)
*Look it's empty*
*I don't have anything,  I'm a piece of shit, no MAGIC*
*huh, how you like that*
HEEEY
IT'S FREE REAL ESTATE
Oh my God, it's Sans
Ohhh, oh Sans.
Where's Papyrus
Come on give it in. Come on.
Give me your head, come on.
oowwhh
ohhhh (seriously?)
Cyka Blyat(Swistian Channel, everybody)
What are you doing
*I'm gonna kiss you*
You can kiss my ass (family friendly Felix)
How bow dah
*Oh yeah come here, Oh yeah*
*Slurp sounds*
No you stop. Nooo, stop.
Goddamit
Nooo
Noo
So creepy
(Technical difficulties)
Can i ride you, come on
Come on, let me get inside
Hey(It's free real estate)
Hey, sensei, you just ran me over.
Oh hell yeah
Ha ha
Hey get out this is my car
*retarded noises*
*this should be in deep web*
*aliens trying to contact earth for signs of intelligence*
*beep beep*
*do you know lwiay?*
You know that song?
He left.
Hey, lilpimpen
Get me the anime girls, right now or you gonna get it.
Hey, Hey listen here
I don't care how tiny and cute you are
Can you believe this
Don't point at me.
Hah
Don't point at me
Okay, I've got a gun
(Nobody cares)
Wait, you have so many friends
Oh my God, can i be your friend
Please, please
I'm like.
I'm an anime girl in real life
I have a really nice
luscious anime tits in real life
but in game i'm John Wick
My seat get up(nice guy pewdiepie)
Excuse me?
*can you stop pointing gun*
You wanna be friends?
Get off the seat
Goodbye
*BLAM*
Technical Difficulties
Hello
No she's here.
I can hear her breath
Hello
The legs are moving
Hey
Jump
Jump or i'll shoot
I'm gonna do it
*Do it*
I am gonna do it
Unless you jump
Hey, Hey, (MONIKA)
listen
I'm doing you a favor here okay?
Jump and no one gets hurt
Oh you gonna Hokage bushin.
OhGoddamit
*laughs*
No shut up. I jumped down on purpose
WhHat's good's wHAt's HapPening?
Let me see how you dab
You wanna see the dab?
Ohh he did it
My dab is cooler man
Look at this man
Jesus christ
Please stay away from me(that's racist)
GO away
Yeah, no buts no buts
because I'm the one with the gun
Yes
Not afraid to shot
*but i love you*
No that's fine
Okay alright, okay alright, you both go in the hole.
Go in the hole
*WHYAREYOUBEINGSOMEANTOME*
(nice smile)
Why didn't you say so
I love you so much
Oh come here
We're bestfriends now
THATS RIGHT
Oh, what a nice dog. (very nice)
Good dog
Stay away from the dog
Back off
[dude 1]*strange noise* Do thumbs like that, can you do that again?
[dude 1] Do that again, your thumb
What's the matter
There's nothing wrong with my thumb
[dude 1]*literally* aihish, hhe aie aah
It's called the potter's thumb, alright?
It's not a condition
It's actually normal
[dude 1] What about the index finger
What's the index finger called?
Fuck are you saying?
[dude 2] Hey what's wrong with your fingers
[dude 2] Look at your fingers dude
There's nothing wrong with my fingers!
*dude 1 laughs*
There's nothing wrong
[dude 2] Yes this is really something
No
[dude 2] Look there's something-
Look, look
This is how fingers work
You've never seen fingers-
[dude 2] What are you looking at that's not how fingers-
This is how fingers look like!
[dude 2] Ok ok, this is my fingers, and look at your fingers
[dude 1] Yeah my fingers don't do that
[dude 2] Do you use (don't understand what's he saying, but something in "your hands)
No, i don't do any of that
Listen, you have never seen fingers, clearly
Look
[dude 2] I have seen fingers
You've never seen fin-
*both talking at the same time and dude 1 laffin*
This is how finger looks like
This is the model finger
*dude 1 laughing*
[dude 2] Oh oh yeah, fingers are supposed to do that?
What you've got u got SCOLIOSIS?
It's not a condition, this is normal
And people like my fingers
I have you know(?) a lot of people compliment me
On my fingers
*some japanese girl talking on the background*
*talking at the same time*
I can tickle with my fingers
PEE TEE TEE TEE TEE TEE
TEE TEE TEE TEE TEE TEE
eKOO KEE KOO KEE(wtf pewds)
[dude 1] It's ok, girls are probably like that (fingers)
KOO TEE KOO TEE
[dude 1] Probably not actually
[dude 2] Hey can you two pick up the women since you are such beautiful mans
Ok yeah ok look at this
Oh look there's a whamen right here
Excuse me milady
Would you like to hold hands
Oh shit
*dudes laughing*
I'll try another one
[dude 2] Wait are we squading?
No squading
[the random japanese girl] no...
Excuse me ladies
[trjg] no (she didn't want retards arround her)
Excuse me ladies?
No? Yes
Why is she is saying no?
I don't understand
Where'd she go?
Excuse me madam
[dude 1] I want to go there, you wanna ask?
I'm just trying show you
I'm tryin' to help you up alright?
Coz I have the fingers, and you don't
[dude 2] I thought you were helping ME out I was trying to get the whamen
Listen, I'm a pick-up artist
I know how to pick-up the ladies
[dude 1] Squading is too slow
Excuse me
[dude 1] Are you sure that's a girl?
This is definitely a girl
[dude 1] She's scary too look!
Excuse me, wanna hold hands?
There is nothing wrong with this hands, trust me.
[dude 2] Watch out x3
[dude 2] I'll show you how to get the women
[dude 2] There's one way to get women
[dude 2] And that's not how
Okay fine, show me >:(
*dude 2's creepy question goes here*
Ok actually he's looking angry
Dude, you are bad as I am
Konichiwa (lol)
[trjg] no way...
Hand hold?
[trjg] Konichiwa
Hold my hand?
*laughs*
There's nothing wrong with it
[dude 1] I'll be your translator: HE WANTS TO HOLD YOUR HAND
[dude 2] Lokathislokat look at his finger
Stop making-!
Listen
Don't look at it.
Just look at this.
Take my hand
OOOOOHHH!!! (smoke weed everyday)
OOHH Look at that! Look at that everybody
Whamen Slayer numbah 1
[dude 2] Whatever dude
das righ
Even if I have hands
(there is a creepy noise on the background like opening a soda drink, I still try to figure out what it is)
I'm in this because I have this hands
[dude 2] Yeah whatever dude
That's right. That's right.
[dude 2] You're nothing alright? you're nothing
Okay, show me then, hah.
[dude 2] Alright I'll show u
Okay
*dude 2 ask a random girl to hold hands, then everybody, well, just watch this poor girl*
[dude 2] You wanna hold my hand?
Don't do it.
They're infected
Oh my God, NO
No oh oh, No
Stace take my hand
Stace
Hold my hand
[dude 2] No don't take his hand if you take his hand...
Come on
Come on Stace
That's right, a little closer
Stace
[dude 2] There you go that's a good idea
Stace!
(poor girl omg)
There's nothing wrong with these ha-
[dude 2] U want to hold hand like that?
*crying(?)*
Eeuuhhh
*the sound of a broken pewds heart*
No one loves me
(except for the random japanese girl right?)
OOOOOOOOOOO
*laughs*
MOST FUNNY PEWDS VIDEO